maybe they're right i spend too much
time in fantasyland
[Music]
what does it feel like i always thought
i wanted this kind of life
i never imagined any of this
get them now
if you save one life
you save the world
cosmetics
i cannot get over the colors man like
the colors are so freaking cool like i
love like the combination of blue and
red i know like some people like are not
the biggest fan but like i just think it
looks like art this looks like art like
an artful hand
this show is beautiful to look at like
every
every shot they've really done a lot to
just like make the image as vibrant uh
and as uh like jumpy off the screen as
possible it feels like one of miss uh
marvel's the common clown's big hands
just reaching out and slapping you in
your couch
she's getting you uh but we're now in
the season of kamala khan so let's dive
into it welcome back a new rock stars
miss marvel is over a little over one
week away
i luckily have been able to see the
first two episodes this time but hey no
spoilers here where i'm gonna get to
some general reactions later this show
not even a real review just some just
some overall thoughts to help uh cushion
you as you join uh this show to help uh
set the tone to set the expectations
where they
really should be um but with all this
debate mt about how this series changed
kamala khan's powers it's really not
spoiling anything to tell all of you
that the reason they changed it is
actually neither because stretchy limbs
are too similar to reed richards nor
because energy manipulation is closer in
power set to captain marvel and monica
rambo no no no there is a third deeper
cooler reason why her powers look the
way they do and i'm gonna begin to
explain why
come on
this is inside marvel and now that we
are staring down the month of june this
is our miss marvel after show here at
new rockstars i'm eric boss here with me
is empty how you doing mt i can't
believe it's finally here my friend i
cannot believe it's finally miss
marvel's season it's like finally she's
in the mcu and like we're so close and
like i can't wait to see it you've
already seen it i'm so jealous what'd
you think like overall general thoughts
i liked it i liked it i was smiling
throughout uh i'll get to some uh
specific uh thoughts and and reactions
at uh later part in the show so stay
with us uh i will get to those um and if
i look a little uh pink it's not just
because i'm blushing over how much i
enjoyed the show it is because uh i
spent all weekend at star wars
celebration and a memorial day weekend
and i was outside
so much fun it was so great meeting
everyone the people who said hello and
and took a picture either with me or of
me uh or people just kind of gave me a
wave like it meant so much to me to
connect with people and just be able to
see all the cool stuff i went to the
mando plus panel uh i went to the
mandalorian experience where they had a
bunch of like they had a huge bantha
that uh talked to me uh they had a
rancor they had all the in one
starfighter they had all the stuff from
the show it was so cool to see what did
they have for size rancor
oh yeah yeah
i'm so jealous
it was a lot of fun
i i hope hopefully i'll be able to go
next year though it's in london so i
don't know if i can make it oh it's in
london i guess we'll see of course
well miss marvel premieres next week
wednesday june 8th so in this episode
we're going to give you a preview of
everything you need to know headed into
miss marvel and i'm gonna give you my no
spoiler reaction to the first two
episodes at the end of this show and
just so you know i want a programming
note to everyone watching or listening
june's gonna get a little sloppy as we
try to cover at the same time obi-wan
kenobi miss marvel and the boys all at
once normally we don't do that normally
we just kind of cover one show at a time
but here we're gonna try to do
simultaneous weekly coverage for all
these shows
and you know what new rockstars is
growing we're gonna have to learn to
multitask here at this company ahead of
september when we're gonna have she-hulk
and andor and house of the dragon and
rings of power all at once four big
shows and for those of you asking
where's our stranger things content
don't worry it's coming it's coming this
week it's just netflix kind of throws a
wrench and all that by dropping all this
stuff at once and we don't have time to
watch it all and do it all in one video
it's so much easier which is episode by
episode then we can just kind of all
watch it at the same time so netflix if
you're listening
join the dark side
of the weekly released content
it's not a race
do it
do it
uh before we talk about miss marvel be
sure to go over to new
rockstarsmerch.com for your chance to
grab our newest latest obsession shirt
empire's most wanted it's a limited
edition shirt inspired by the new obi
wan kenobi series when you purchase it
you're going to get the chance to unlock
a shout out that will appear on
wikileaks our obi-wan kenobi after show
so check out all the new kenobi merch
options from epic hero shop over at
newrockstarsmerch.com
all right mt what are we talking about
this week all right bro i gotta ask you
bro it's like the biggest question that
a lot of people got
how did miss kamala khan really get her
super powers yes so uh for the first
concept art and trailer footage back in
november uh really one conversation has
driven the discourse over the mcu
version of kamala khan and that is her
powers uh in the comics kamala gets hit
with a terrigen mist that allows her to
change her molecular structure so that
she can stretch or embiggen her body
parts in the mcu series they've changed
it so that she can manipulate energy
into crystalline shapes and shields
floating lily pads she can make her own
arms stretch out her hand bigger and in
the way that green lantern sort of can
with like a
coating of energy that changes rather
than her actual hand changing shape um
but to understand really what's going on
with this change we gotta break down in
general what we should really know about
the character from the comics going into
this series uh so empty why don't you
take it from here yeah so the most
influential comic story line to this
series is of course kamala khan's first
solo series miss marvel vol 3 number one
in 2014 by g willow wilson kamala khan
was made a brief cameo as a fan girl in
a 2013 captain marvel comic and there
was such a huge reaction for that
character that g willow wilson conceived
a new spin-off series for the character
yeah and it's a really really cool
series that uh we highly recommend you
check out um so the the way in in the
backstory of the comics what's going on
here is thanos has traveled to earth
looking for his son and that leads to a
conflict between thanos and blackpole
that led to blackpole detonating a uh
terrigen bomb that caused the terrorist
mist to spread uh throughout the
tri-state area including jersey city so
kamala khan's a very big fan of uh
captain marvel she's a pakistani
american teenager living in jersey city
she's walking around gets hit with this
mist and this mist is uh what causes
stereogenesis that's how you make
inhumans in the marvel war but uh kamala
goes into this cocoon where inside she
envisions her three favorite avengers
captain marvel captain america and iron
man and initially when she comes out of
that cocoon she actually takes the form
of the blonde carol danvers um and then
while she's in this form she uses her
limp stretching powers to save the life
of the popular girl slash bully zoe
zimmer but she won't stay a bully she
has a nice change of heart and it's it's
beautiful to see her character arc
throughout these comics um but then
later on kamala realizes that she
doesn't need to look like carol danvers
she can just look like herself and still
have these powers right so that's how
she ends up left with this uh the
stretchy ability and a bit of a healing
power as many superheroes have they have
like rapid healing
it's a good thing to have when you're
punching bad guys tell you what yeah um
and of course this 2014 kamala khan
storyline was a major success for marvel
comics or else we wouldn't be here right
now talking about right um and largely
because of the characterization of
kamala her sense of humor her pakistani
american muslim heritage her perspective
as a fan observer of the avengers which
is a very important perspective because
that's what we are we are fans so like
we love seeing things through her eyes
um and she would quickly join the
avengers team up with the wolverine the
the grumpiest man of all time and then
team up with the champion which included
miles morales sam alexander nova amares
cho hook uh vision's daughter vivian who
is great and a time displaced cyclops
yeah it's a really fun ragtag team of uh
of young avengers but they are not the
young avengers necessarily that this is
a different team in the mcu we'll see
maybe kamala khan will join some kind of
mix of these groups uh with a lot of
different members of it uh but one thing
readers and players of the game that has
kamala khan as a point of view character
really relate to about kamala khan's
stretchy limbs is that for them it
serves as a metaphor for puberty like
parts of your body awkwardly growing out
of proportion with other parts dealing
with that awkwardness and learning how
to own it you could say it's similar to
sam raimi's take on spider-man the
webbing being uh like excreted from his
rights yeah i think it's meant to be
gross and then you learn to be okay with
that grossness actually put the two
those two together but you're so 1 000
right like kamal's powers when she first
gets them it's very puberty-like and
like it's just yeah and like i feel like
a lot of teens especially you know
people who used to be teens like me a
long time ago
um it was uh it really just feels like
what is happening to me like my body is
betraying like everything feels weird so
like yeah yeah such a puberty story but
yeah in the in the mcu kamala khan is
confirmed to return in the marvels aka
captain marvel 2 alongside brie larson
carol danvers and tayonna paris monica
rambo in july 2023 yeah and i think uh
some of the mcu cynics may look at that
future team up and then just kind of
conclude well that must be why they're
doing what they're doing they look at
all these characters being introduced as
really cogs in a machine as opposed to
uh characters on their own journeys with
their own character development arcs i
think we have to remember though in
these disney plus shows we're going to
be spending six episodes with this
person and we're going to get to know
the person on a more intimate level than
we have right a lot of the characters in
the movies um and i think it's fair to
assume that uh you know if if her powers
are now looking just cosmic generally
cosmic that that does seem a bit more
similar to uh to carol danvers captain
marvel and uh monica rambo photon but we
don't fully know how their powers work
even coming out of uh the captain marvel
film
it was caused by a light speed engine
cosmic radiation from an infinity stone
but it wasn't exactly the tesseract it
was like power derived from the
tesseract right um and then we have no
idea what's going on with photon we just
know that when she passed through the
hex wall of west view it powered her up
um
also some people are saying that marvel
studios maybe just wanted to avoid
similarity to reed richards
and i i get why you might make that
conclusion but marvel has never actually
said that in fact here's what kevin
feige told empire let's read his quote
he said we adapt the comics it's not an
exact translation kamala came about in a
very specific time within the comic book
continuity she is now coming into a very
specific time within the mcu continuity
and those two things didn't match what
we will learn about where those powers
come from and how they come about is
specific to the mcu you will see great
comic splash panels in some of our
action sequences if you want big giant
hands and arms while they're here in
spirit if not in stretchy plastic type
ways
so reading that
my question is what does kevin feige
mean by quote a very specific time
within the mcu continuity and stretchy
limbs not matching with that
and there's a few explanations we can
look at a quick one that i want to
dismiss is that stretchy limbs are too
similar to reed richards i don't think
kevin feige would care if kamala khan's
stretchy limbs are too similar to read
richard's stretchy limbs he already
brought in reed richards and multiverse
of madness and did away with him quickly
if we had another character who was like
miss incredible you know i don't think
helen parr i don't think they would
really care just because marvel studios
has redundant power sets all over the
place and it doesn't uh it doesn't
diminish any other character if anything
they love it when they bring back
redundant powers so like how many super
soldiers do we have in the mcu like they
love to make every hero and villain come
from the same kind of power set cap
versus red skull they were both
different versions of super soldiers
bucky was a super soldier in the second
one of those movies uh thor and loki and
valkyrie and jane now are all asgardians
similar power sets we have hulk and a
shield similar power sets right so we
have multiple sorcerers in the mcu with
pretty much the same power sets
so i think it'd be okay to have multiple
stretchy people um but if uh and also
indeed if this were true that marvel was
worried about this at all you would
think that marvel studios would want to
make kamala powers different from carol
and monica not similar as you're saying
that they are
um like i think they'd be a worried
about kamala having the similar power
sets so one possible explanation is that
this is actually what they want is that
kamala khan's powers will come from the
same kind of origin as captain marvel so
if i were to try if you were to press me
to try to explain
captain marvel's powers it's some
combination of cree technology cree tech
i guess maybe scroll tech you know
cosmic tech between these two alien
races and then cosmic racing and then
cosmic radiation coming from an infinity
stone from the tesseract space stone um
or what we saw with monica rambo photon
which is currently unknown we don't know
what happened to her when she was an
astronaut for sword but uh and this
would have been before the blip but in
her case it's some mix of cosmic
radiation because she passed through the
hex wall which is made up of cmdr cosmic
microwave background radiation and it's
something else extraterrestrial
as as an astronaut uh we don't fully
know yet what her backstory was she was
touched by e.t
right on the nose
it works
um but uh again i have seen the first
two episodes i i'm not gonna discuss the
origins of their powers because that
isn't even fully answered in the first
two episodes so i couldn't even spoil it
even if i wanted to
uh but just going by the trailer footage
alone we can derive a lot of this her
powers seem to come from these bracelet
cuffs and uh
these cuffs may have an alien origin
they might be cree designs we don't
really know yet but i think the missing
but i think we're all missing the
context within which kamala finds these
cuffs they're hidden in her own family's
attic these are artifacts tied to her
own family history they might be alien
originally but that part of it is not as
important as the way they represent her
pakistani heritage
and i think that is going to be the key
thing we explore i think the creatives
behind this show shows that uh saw that
maybe superpower superpowers as a
metaphor for puberty is already kind of
done with things like samurai spider-man
and shazam uh
we have an opportunity here to view
superpowers as they intersect with a
young pakistani american's family
history and i think that is a very
interesting direction to go um and when
you think about kevin feige's quote what
that means a very specific time in mcu
continuity
i don't think
he's referring to rainbow colored cosmic
whatever we don't is that really the
the period we're now in in the mcu
timeline we don't know what that is that
kind of like
cosmic energy that i'm manipulating and
it's all super vague i don't think kevin
feige's like eager
to make that the definitive symbol in
the definitive theme of this era i think
what he's referring to mt is religion
what we believe whom we pray to and when
you think about it we're all wondering
what direction mcu phase four is going
look at the titles eternals moon knight
thor love and thunder black panther
wakanda forever
to an extent the darkhold and multiverse
of madness all of these titles are about
spirituality belief systems afterlives
sacred texts gods
in kamala khan's world
as a devout muslim teenager well i don't
know how devout she is personally what
her family is varied about
fits perfectly into that so whatever
origin this series gives those cuffs
again i still do not know originally how
they got in into her family's attic but
i think their importance will be tied to
the faith of her pakistani muslim family
and just be clear here i am not saying
that the mcu is gonna depict allah or
the prophet muhammad seated alongside
zeus in love and thunder
i think that would be pretty problematic
in a lot of ways uh but i do think
whatever magic or tech is in these
bracelets is at least activated or
connected to kamala's religious beliefs
uh and i think we're gonna learn how
everybody who is uh who prays everyone
who believes
who is about anything in this universe
uh has a certain kind of power uh has is
unlocks a certain kind of ability uh
that takes a different form
depending on who you are and whom you
pray to um but that's gonna be a core
part of a human identity is having
something to believe in or someone to
believe in i really like that connection
that you made cause like you're so
you're really right because like this
phase is very spiritual based and it's
very like religious-y in a way with like
especially with moonlight this is so
true and like i feel like faith is going
to be a huge part of like the way this
next phase moves and like um especially
with camilla khan and like her own like
not just with her faith in like her
religion but like also just faith in
herself and i feel like um like
believing in yourself is going to be a
huge theme of this show and like um i
feel like that there's going to be that
connection between like belief in
yourself maybe like a spiritual belief
that like you know
is going to carry this face forward is
probably going to carry the show forward
so i really love that connection i never
made that uh like connection before it's
because it's so true and i i think the
mcu's not gonna be so bold as uh saying
a major world religion is now has some
kind of like fictional counterpart in
the mcu no i'm not saying that because
up until now all the religions that
they've kind of adopted are either
really really old mythology style ones
like norse mythology or egyptian
mythology uh or like wakandan mythology
and you don't have like active uh
churches right now who are praying to
to those kind of belief systems whereas
islam is obviously massive across the
ground so
um i don't think they're doing that but
i think what they're saying is that uh
the things that are important to you and
your spiritual beliefs um
when
these kind this kind of magic or this
kind of technology
makes a connection with you uh
it allows what is in your heart to
dictate what your reality is we've
talked about that a lot empty with uh
with like wanda maximoff with people who
can manipulate reality around them with
uh
with the quantum realm even quantum
realm has that kind of like
thought dictates reality uh essence to
it and that is directly from the pages
of kamala khan's 2014 arc with g willa
wilson like that when she goes in that
cocoon it really is just what's in her
mind and then that ends up it's like a
wish fulfillment aspect um but the mcu
is challenged to do that in a different
way that we haven't seen before it can't
just be shazam right it can't just be
spider-man like a kid it needs to be
something that is specific to her and i
think the shape of this magic or this
energy this cosmic energy it is cosmic
in nature of course the back that is
like
uh tactile it is
crystalline but it's still
brittle it can still be shot at and
crumbled you know uh i think that's
gonna be something specific to her
family history um
like i'm wondering with the kevin feige
quote like in regards to like the mcu
not being there or like at the specific
time or whatever he was saying like i
wonder if he's referring to like the
terrorism bomb like you're bringing up
earlier because like i i wonder if
that's going to be
introduced into the mcu eventually but
kevin feige is like we haven't got to
the bomb yet so because we haven't got
to the bomb here are these beautiful
powers enjoy them for now and then later
will get really stretchy and weird and
have a big hand like you like you like
them but like i wonder if we're going to
get that bomb because that'd be i would
love to see because like that may be one
of my favorite parts in that hole and i
think we are ready for terrigen mist in
the mcu if we're ready for all the other
crap that they're putting in these shows
and in these movies i think we're ready
for that too like come on
how many years is like
the marvel franchise really gonna be
relevant just start cashing in on it all
right like and then you can heighten it
from other places from there i don't
know
that's my biggest gripe with emc right
now is like we're not ready for mutants
yet
we've been ready for muses for like 10
years
it's so true we're always ready for
beans what are we not ready for
what are we waiting for like
just just you could have uh gotten
you could have doubled your disney plus
subscribers if you just announced an
aurora monroe storm series at disney
plus day back in november just don't
even give a release date just say we're
doing storm and then everyone's like i'm
going to subscribe because x-men are
here now and storm is awesome like why
are they waiting well like
yes please oh thank you for announcing
uh
an echo series great okay cool i like
echo but like you have a ton of really
cool characters do a lot for a lot of
fans uh anyway um but uh the
i think the thing with
kamala khan's powers i really i'm not so
attached because i was not a teenager
when i was reading those qualicon comics
so i i didn't necessarily need like uh
her hands to be able to stretch or
whatever and it looks like from trailer
footage she has a big hand she has big
fists you know he's right there they're
in spirit and i think when he says in
spirit i there might be a double meaning
there right like i think what he's
getting at here
is that it is about one's uh one spirit
one soul and i think that's gonna be the
link with all these things uh and uh
i'll tell you i'm enjoying the series
just fine so far it's not right it's not
gonna know i was like very interested to
hear your thoughts because like i was
like is it good is it actually good so
like i'm glad that you had a good time
with it well i'm going to give you some
uh slightly more specific takes on this
in just a moment but first i want to
thank some friends who helped us make
this episode thank you to helix sleep
for sponsoring this episode with all
this great new content coming out it is
important that both mt and i get a great
night's sleep so that we could be well
rested enough to spot all the easter
eggs the hidden details and that's why
i'm glad to have a helix mattress helix
sleep has a quiz that takes just two
minutes to complete and matches your
body type new sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you they have soft
medium and burn mattresses mattresses
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot it mattress is great for his final
alignment to prevent morning aches and
pains both mt and i have helix
mattresses we love them so just go to
helix sleep.com slash inside marvel take
their two minute sleep quiz and they'll
match you to a customized mattress it'll
give you the best sleep of your life
they have a 10-year warranty and you get
to try it out for 100 nights risk-free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it it's probably why helix
was awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020 by gq in wired
magazine helix is offering up to 200 off
all mattress orders and two three
pillows for our listeners at helix
sleep.com insidemarvel again that's
helixsleep.com insidemarvel also we want
to thank raycon for sponsoring this
episode i prefer to watch all my shows
on the biggest tv i can but when i have
to watch content on the go i'm so glad
to have some raycon wireless earbuds
raycon's everyday earbuds look feel and
sound better than ever with optimized
gel tips for the perfect in-ear fit
these earbuds stay put and feel
comfortable raycons offer three sound
profiles to match what you're listening
to plus noise isolation and awareness
mode so that you can choose to be
immersed in sound or be able to hear
your surroundings when you need to
raycons are perfect for getting great
sound on the go raycons give you 8 hours
of play time and a 32 hour battery life
then when you need charge it's super
easy you do it wirelessly with raycons
you get the same quality audio as other
premium audio brands but at half the
price and raycon's everyday earbuds have
over 49 000 five-star reviews check out
raycon's wireless earbuds for yourself
go to buyrecon.com
marvel today to get 15 off your raycon
order that's by raycon dot com slash
marvel to score 15 off by recon dot com
marvel all right mt back to miss marvel
i want to give you my reaction to watch
this i want to hear it like what you
think i'm not going to spoil anything
for anybody um and i'm not even going to
give you a full review because
technically disney's review embargo is
still in effect until next week but i
can give you some general thoughts on
this show um just to help you frame how
to go into this show i think it's
helpful to have that you know no
spoilers of course but just like yes
what can i expect so in many ways ms
marvel is going to diverge from the mcu
formula because the look and the tone
are just so much closer to scott pilgrim
in turning red
right i love scott two movies that i
really liked um it uh it is a teenage
coming of age story uh and the way it
connects with being a superhero so it is
similar in a lot of ways to uh
spider-man homecoming the the tom
holland mcu movies it's about a high
school kid trying to grapple with being
a superhero uh all the spider-man movies
really deal with this spider-man into
the spider-verse there's a lot of uh
parallels with that uh there's also
movies like shazam we mentioned before
there's a lot of that wish fulfillment
you know um but if there's still any
part of you that is connected with your
high school self either your own
memories that you're still like trying
to figure out uh or maybe if you have
younger siblings or kids or relatives if
you yourself are a teenager um i really
i think anyone should be able to relate
with this i i don't get the complaint
like oh i couldn't relate with it
because i'm not a kid myself like
it's just super charming like i think if
you
have any kind of connection with this is
like a genre of story of kids going
through if you as an adult watch the
harry potter movies and watch kids going
through this you can connect with a
child we were all kids ourselves at one
point so it's either going to be
nostalgic for us or it's going to be
humorous for us we should all be able to
relate with it i think the only people
who are going to have trouble relating
with it are people who are younger than
being in high school if you're like six
or seven or eight it might be hard for
you to connect with this which i don't
know i had older siblings as a six seven
and eight year old and watched teenage
shows and movies i watched dawson's
creek when i was nine years old and
found a way to connect with it so i
think you can connect with this um i
understand if you may not be in the mood
for uh teenage angst i think
what you see in the trailer is what
you're going to get in the show and as
with the trailer your mileage may vary
with the show um but uh you know if it's
not you if you are not in the mood to
connect with teenage angst i totally get
it but just don't turn around and tell
me that you love spider-man homecoming
and spider-man into the spider-verse
because those movies are at their heart
teenage angst movies they're all kind of
age things they hit the same beats uh
and i think miss marvel is wholesome and
hilarious and such a delight to watch
and i and i
i hope that everyone really loves it um
and yes we touched on in the first half
of the episode how much the show goes
into what it means to be a a teenager
who comes from a pakistani-american
muslim family that
that goes to a mosque and prays and then
deals with like the the community
within the community like the
uh there's just like a lot of fun world
building there uh and you get a sense of
it it's educational in a lot of ways
it's eye-opening in a lot of ways and i
really really appreciated that about it
i love to watch shows about people who
are just different from the world i come
from i think it's just very enlightening
and it's uh it's just wonderful i i try
to watch it it's just less boring like
why do you want to watch things that
you're like only if you are familiar
with like why would you do that like it
just looks like i mean
i love both right so i watched uh
comment on miss marvel this weekend a
different world i watched top gun
maverick this weekend very much loved
that and i come from a navy pilot family
it was the world i came from and i love
that as well
so i get you know things that you can
connect with more uh i like that but
another thing that i think is obvious
from the trailers uh and again not
spoiling anything here it's just how
much the series embraces fandom as a
concept and i think this is the case
more than any other mcu title this
series explores what it means to be a
fan of the avengers and it places it
within the mcu and i think it's really
cool because it explores both sides of
it the wild escapism but also the limits
of one's individuality by being too
obsessed with things like cosplay
um and i think cosplay can be a great
way to show your individuality but i
think if like it becomes your world too
much
and these fictional universes or these
other people who are not yourself if
that's the only thing that you have i
think it can be a whole that you get
trapped in i think it helps to have a
nice balance i think it's a really cool
escapism to have to be uh to love a
franchise but it also can show the
limits and and sometimes the
frustrations the burdens of being like
too obsessed with things like cosplay
right like you don't uh it's inherently
a mask and people love your costume but
they don't necessarily love you
underneath so if uh it's like it's in a
fun way the issues that like spider-man
has to deal with like they love the the
spider-man or they hate the spider-man
they just don't know the person
underneath the mask so it uh it's a fun
character arc for kamala to have to go
through to have to figure out who she is
underneath this costume and uh and
is she just a captain marvel fan girl or
is she her own superhero i think that's
a really love that like i never really
thought about like imagine cosplaying
somebody in real life like somebody that
actually exists that's actually a hero i
feel like that changes your psyche that
changes like because like when people
cosplay it's like all right batman he's
not real he's from a comic book but like
if captain marvel is flying around
actually saving people and like you're
dressing up as her that's going to like
make you not want to be yourself almost
so like i never really thought about it
from that perspective yeah like she's
cosplaying like
it'd be like cosplaying like lebron or
cosplay
instead of cosplaying as thor
right
that is what it is in this world so it's
basically it's a little weird to see i
think it's uh you know
the boys explores this a lot like these
superheroes as celebrities in the world
and what that would mean
and it's weird uh to to see people
cosplaying as these figures when they're
just like real life people who actually
exist they're not escapist fictional
characters that people just find a
connection with and want to express that
through cosplay uh so it's a little
weird to see people cosplaying as these
people in the within the mcu i don't
know if people would do it the same way
but obviously people do and so kamala's
figuring out like when she has this uh
this ability to power up like
does she need to just be uh like a
replicant of
a carol danvers no she doesn't need to
be she can be her own thing and i think
that's what she's discovering on the
show and i i think it's really cool to
explore those themes what it means to be
a fandom and as marvel youtubers
i mean i feel seen watching the show
because we have learned in interviews
that uh the actress who plays kamalakon
iman vilani is herself a major marvel
nerd she keeps a notebook filled with
mcu trivia and questions and just like
factoids about the mcu
and uh and cigar who plays kamala's
older brother amir actually
we've chatted a few times in real life i
saw him at the multiverse madness
premiere facebook friends i'm not really
sure he he's a friend of a friend
through like the ucb comedy scene in l.a
uh and we chatted a couple times he
confirmed to me that iman watches new
rockstars videos if you're watching
great job on on miss marvel you're a
delight oh you're wonderful hello
hopefully we can get uh i think we're
gonna try to get some of these uh actors
on the show if we can't please on the
channel amman if you
[Music]
yeah i mean really anyone from the show
we're gonna anyway we love you all um
but uh but you can totally see when you
watch the show how kamala the character
absolutely exists in a world where
marvel youtube theories just run wild
so like it almost feels like we're about
to get referenced when you watch the
show
i would throw up in happiness
so in addition to the uh or no it almost
feels like when uh uh jimmy wu wrote
hexagons on the on the dry erase board
right it's like
is he watching our videos when did they
add that
like it's kind of creepy or in loki
episode five when a classic loki said
like basically his backstory was exactly
a theory we talked about on this channel
like it just feels like the worlds are
overlapping now and it's kind of
exciting
terrifying but exciting bro if i see
like an eric boss sticker like on miss
marvel's binder or something i'm gonna
freak out
i'm gonna lose my mind yeah it's gonna
be
yeah
um so i just think in addition to all
the important conversations that are
happening on this series like uh
obviously what it means to be a
pakistani-american muslim and the
representation that we can all learn
from uh by having this character now in
the mcu obviously that's going to be an
important theme on the show but i also
just think it's conversation about
marvel fandom it's gonna be one that i
think we're all going to feel sharp
pangs of familiarity from and i think
it's gonna be something we absolutely
should explore and talk more about um
but uh i'll leave it there for now i i
don't want to i don't want to say too
much about the plot and what happens on
the show i think it's it's a fun thing
for you to discover yourself um so we'll
leave it there for this episode of
inside marvel but uh next week on
wednesday bright and early empty and i
are going to have our reactions
to episode one here on here on the
channel in our inside marvel after show
so uh just so you know we're gonna be
doing simultaneous content for miss
marvel and for obi-wan kenobi uh the
fact that i think i'm gonna be able to
get mt to be able to see episode one a
little early we should be able to get
the uh inside marvel uh miss marvel
reaction up first thing next wednesday
wednesday the eighth uh the obi-wan
kenobi wikileaks reaction will come out
a little bit later in the day because we
don't get that right away tommy and i
don't we get it when you guys do so yeah
we're we're gonna figure it all out
you're gonna get all your content uh and
uh yeah i think i think we have a big
enough t now to where we can handle it
all right at marvel marvel if you want
to move those one of those shows to a
different day it'd be great
we won't complain we won't complain
uh
great
so don't forget to check out our many
great merch options over at
newrockstarsmerge.com follow me at ea
boss follow mt and mastertainment
subscribe to inside marvel wherever you
get your podcasts thank you for watching
we'll see you next week bye love you
guys
you